you
hello everyone good evening I'm Susan
call and on behalf of our owners and our
entire staff I'd like to welcome you to
politics and prose before we get started
this would be a good time to turn off or
silence your cellphone's also after the
event if you don't mind helping us by
folding up your chairs we'd be grateful
and during our question-and-answer
session we have a microphone right here
so if you could line up with your
questions that would be helpful because
we are recording this event and c-span
is here as well you can also watch this
on our YouTube channel in just a few
days also on your way out please pick up
one of our April calendars and take a
look at all of the great events we have
forthcoming both here and at our three
Busboys and poets locations we've also
got some great trips and classes I'm
honored to welcome Adam Hoch shield back
to politics and prose this evening to
discuss his powerful new book Spain in
our hearts which is an account of
American involvement in the Spanish
Civil War and a consideration of the
perceived romance that attracted 2800
Americans to Spain a quarter of whom
died which was the largest number of
Americans before or since to join
someone else's Civil War this strangely
literary war that famously attracted the
likes of Ernest Hemingway and George
Orwell of course turned out to be
extremely morally complex and hokey
shield demonstrates the nuanced ways in
which the political alignments that
formed at the time turned out to be the
prequel to world war ii the book is just
out and getting great reviews including
in the new york times which called his
account
excellent and involving he's also the
co-founder of Mother Jones magazine and
the author of
books including King Leopold's ghost
which was a finalist for the National
Book Critics Circle Award as was his
recent to end all wars
he's also been a finalist for the
National Book Award and he won the Los
Angeles Times Book Prize and a pen USA
literary award we're so honored to have
him here to launch this new book please
help me welcome Adam Hoch shield Thank
You Susan it's great to be here in this
wonderful store and I know if I lived in
Washington DC I would spend so much time
here they would go have me arrested for
loitering it's also nice to see so many
friends here from the worlds of
journalism and book writing so many of
you in fact that it makes me fear we're
just writing for each other I hope
that's not the case anyway it's a
pleasure to have a chance to tell you
something about my new book to begin
let's sort of mentally run the clock
back to the 1930s the setting in which
these events took place it was a grim
time here in the United States the Great
Depression was taking a terrible toll
roughly 1/3 rest roughly 1/4 of the
American working population was out of
work
34 million Americans were living in
households with no cash income abroad
similar conditions and in the aftermath
of World War one some even nastier
things as well Hitler was on the rise
finally came to power in Germany in 1933
Mussolini already had been in power
since the 1920s in Italy much of Eastern
Europe was under far-right regimes with
a anti-semitic tinge fascism was
definitely on the rise oddly enough in
the 1930s the early 1930s
one of the very few bright spots was
Spain in 1931 centuries of monarchy
recently interwoven with a period of
military dictatorship came to an end the
King left the country national
democratic elections were held real real
ones for the very first time and at last
it seemed democracy was coming to a
country that sorely needed it there was
much work to be done
education up to this point had been in
the hands of the Catholic Church and the
Catholic hierarchy in Spain was by far
the most reactionary in Europe separate
education for boys and girls education
for girls was heavy on sewing and
religion not much else there were huge
disparities of wealth most of the land
was in the hands of very large
landowners owning enormous estates
millions of peasants had little or no
land at all and worked as laborers on
these estates and more than a quarter of
the population was illiterate highest
percentage in Western Europe in early
1936 small D Democrats and progressives
all over the world felt a further surge
of optimism because in the Spanish
elections in February of that year a
coalition of left and liberal parties
won and so there were promises of
further reform speeding up the process
of land reform for example speeding up
the process of secularization of
education and much more that this
country seemed to very badly need then
in July of 1936 there was a great shock
felt around the world because there was
a widespread extremely well coordinated
revolt by right-wing army officers who
called themselves nationalists and very
quickly emerging as leader of this group
was a tough-talking young general
named Francisco Franco most of the
Spanish army went with this was a revolt
what did the Spanish nationalists want
they wanted to restore the old Spain a
Spain where power was held by the big
landowners the major industrialists
education would be given back entirely
to the Catholic Church and the army
would remain supreme it would be a
military dictatorship there would be no
free press no free trade unions no
democratic trappings of any sort and a
very quick indication of what the real
politics of this revolt were came
because immediately jumping in to help
Franco and his nationalist within a
matter of days were Adolphe Hitler and
Benito Mussolini both sent planes pilots
tanks tank drivers military advisors
military equipment of all kinds and
Mussolini before long sent eighty
thousand ground troops as well the
Spanish Civil War had begun the war was
basically between those forces and the
quite ragtag her remaining armed forces
that stayed loyal to the elected
government of the Spanish Republic now
something that made this different from
any war that had been seen in Europe in
quite a long time was the way political
violence was deliberately targeted at
civilians in areas that the Nationalists
controlled or took over there was
widespread targeting targeted killing of
any civilians who had been in any way
part of or known supporters of the
previous elected government of the
Spanish Republic a hundred and fifty
thousand civilians were killed in
nationalist controlled territory during
the war and another twenty thousand
afterwards there was a lot of violence
on the other side as
well in the spanish republic mobs killed
an estimated 49,000 people who were
presumed or known to be sympathizers of
the Spanish nationalists and nearly
7,000 of them were members of the clergy
the Catholic Church being so identified
with the big landowners and the
nationalist movement an extremely
violent war that was very violent in
other ways as well
conditions in the prisons especially
those maintained by the Spanish
nationalists were absolutely abysmal
their emblem of yoke and arrows was
branded on the breasts of dissident
women there was a kind of almost
medieval level to this cruelty that had
really not been seen in this venomous
away in Europe on such a large scale for
quite a long time now as this conflict
developed and spread quite rapidly with
more and more of Spain falling under the
control of the nationalist rebels the
elected government of the Spanish
Republic pleaded desperately with the
major democracies Britain France the
United States to sell it arms and
actually Republican Spain had the money
to buy those arms because they had the
world's four they had the world's fourth
largest gold reserves during World War
one when all the major other other major
nations of Europe had been spending
themselves into debt fighting that
horrible war there had been an economic
boom in Spain but all of the democracies
refused to sell arms to the Spanish
Republic in the United States
isolationism was very strong this was
the period of America first very strong
sentiment against being drawn into
anybody else's civil war similar
feelings really were ran through the
governments of Britain and France within
a few months the rebel Spanish
nationalists controlled
half the country's territory with a
continued very very thick stream of help
from Hitler and Mussolini eventually at
that point the fall of 1936 about three
months after the revolt had began the
only government that stepped forward to
sell arms to Republican Spain was not
another democracy it was Joseph Stalin's
Soviet Union and although it was not
widely known at the time Stalin demanded
a lot of things in return for selling
arms to Spain namely high positions for
Spanish and Soviet communists in the
government's armed forces leadership and
in their security forces but Stalin did
something more important as well which
is that he passed the word to communist
parties around the world wanting to take
an advantage of this enormous
groundswell of enthusiastic support for
the Spanish Republic past the world
words of the world's communist parties
begin recruiting volunteers to fight for
the Spanish Republic and these
volunteers were what became known as the
International Brigades which I'm sure
you're familiar with eventually thirty
five to forty thousand people from more
than 50 countries went to Spain to fight
for the Spanish Republic they were the
shock troops of this war they were
thrown into the very toughest battles
and the men in those International
Brigades died at three times the rate of
other soldiers in the Spanish Republic
army among them were some 2800 Americans
most though not though by no means all
of them members or sympathizers of the
American Communist Party it was by far
the largest group of Americans ever to
go and fight in somebody else's Civil
War why did they go above all I think it
was a sense that the greatest threat
that the world faced
at that moment was a rapidly expanding
fascism something that sooner or later
would threaten all countries one
American volunteer Maury Colo of New
York said at one point for us after
speaking about after it's said for us it
was never Franco
it was always Hitler another American
volunteer Hyman Katz who was actually a
23 year old rabbi wrote to his mother
from Spain several months before he was
killed they're saying that if he hadn't
come forever after he would ask himself
why didn't I wake up when the alarm
clock rang now one thing that made me
interested in writing about this subject
was that I knew half a dozen of these
American volunteers all 30 or 40 years
older than me all of them dead now so
here they were fighting a brutal war
really in many ways the first battle of
World War two
after all where else in the world where
were Americans in uniform being bombed
by Nazi pilots for years before the
world before the United States entered
World War two on one side you had the
Spanish Republican Army and these
international volunteers on the other
side heavily supported by Hitler and
Mussolini you had the Spanish
nationalists and by this point
Hitler was realizing that Spain was a
priceless opportunity for him to try out
the weapons he was planning to use in
the larger war to come which of course
he was already busily planning and all
of the most famous German weapons of the
Second World War had their first combat
trial in Spain the Messerschmitt 109
fighter plane the Stuka dive-bomber the
88 millimeter artillery piece much
feared by US soldiers during World War
two
all of these were first experienced and
were first experienced by Americans as
their targets
during the Spanish Civil War now when
you have a patch of history like this a
piece of history that is so colorful so
dramatic so tragic a book almost writes
itself and sometimes I felt as if I was
steering a ship through this
extraordinary set of waters and the only
decisions I have to make were who to
take on board in other words through
what characters am I going to try to
tell this story because I like to try to
bring a piece of history alive by
telling it through the lives of people
who live through it and it makes the
story all the better
I think if when you assemble a cast of
characters like this you can find people
who knew each other whose paths crossed
who loved each other or who hated each
other or were bitter rivals and I found
some of all of the above and of course
as a historian you can't invent anything
so you have to find people who left a
record memoirs diaries letters or show
up in other documents do historians a
favor by the way and keep a diary these
are just gold mines when you find them I
don't have time to tell you about all
the characters in the book but here are
some of them I wanted to show what the
experience of some of these American
volunteers were like so I followed
several of them one was a young man
named Bob Merriman who became one of the
highest-ranking Americans in Spain
partly by accident because when he had
been a college undergraduate working his
way through college at the University of
Nevada at Reno he had discovered that
you could earn an extra eight dollars
and fifty cents a month which was a lot
of money in those days
by taking ROTC so he did so and that
meant that when he got to Spain a few
years later he was one of the very few
Americans who had any kind of military
training at all
his wife Marian also went to Spain she
was the only American woman in uniform
at International Brigades headquarters
where she worked as a clerk I had known
in choosing them to write about it I'd
known that Bob Merriman had been a
graduate student at Berkeley for a few
years before going to Spain I was
astonished in going through their
letters to each other to discover that
they had lived only a couple of blocks
were from where I do today and every
time I walk from my house to the
Graduate School of Journalism at
Berkeley where I teach a class I walk
past the building where they lived it
was a very poignant love story between
the two of them they were very much in
love she had first gone to Spain to
nurse him when he was wounded then he
recovered went back into action she
stayed there in the spring of 1938 after
having been in Spain almost a year and a
half he went missing in action and his
body was never found and she didn't know
exactly how he died because it was
during a chaotic retreat 49 years after
his death she got a letter from a
Spanish soldier saying I had to keep my
head down all the years of the Franco
dictatorship but now I can tell you I
was with your husband when he died and
here's where it was in writing the book
I went to Spain and I went to the spot
where he was last seen alive I was
intrigued by Bob and Marian Merriman
because I found them highly simpatico
people as indeed did everybody who met
them in this period and there are
abundant records from all sorts of
people volunteers journalists US
government officials anybody you can
think of finding this this couple
charming and charismatic but I was
intrigued by them because the
they were true believing communists
never had a moment's doubt and in in
this respect they were typical of many
if not most of the Americans who went
there at that time I wanted to follow a
few other volunteers as well and one of
them I picked because he was distinctly
non-communist in fact he wrote quite
humorously that he felt the Communists
always acted as if they had the correct
answer for everything and had no sense
of humor and that if you made a
political joke in a communist meeting it
was treated as if you had farted in
church but he appreciated that the
Communist Party was were the only people
who were organizing on a large scale to
send volunteers to Spain and so he went
and fought with them his name was Pat
gurney he was actually British but he
fought through the war he fought through
the war in the American battalion and
was a very shrewd and thoughtful
observer of what he saw when should I
worry about that sound okay when at one
point he was wounded he was sent to the
American Hospital and fell in love with
an American nurse Toby Jen ski of New
York it's always fun when you can
reconstruct a love affair in this case
we have letters from her by the way keep
your letters especially your love
letters during future historians another
favor we have letters from her we have a
memoir from him we have an account from
somebody who knew them both well there
who said things didn't happen at all the
way he described in his memoir so it's
wonderful fun trying to put these events
like this together from multiple sources
ah another type of character I was
interested in were the American
journalists who covered the war the war
was a huge story during the almost three
years that had raged there were more
than a
in front page New York Times stories
about the Spanish Civil War more than on
any other single subject whether the
re-election of President Roosevelt the
toll of the Great Depression the rise of
Hitler anything else there were nearly a
thousand foreign correspondents in Spain
at one point or another during the war
not just from the United States but from
many other countries as well now I
usually like to avoid writing about
people who are already well known but if
you're writing about Americans in the
Spanish Civil War you can't avoid the
figure of Ernest Hemingway he was there
so much of the time he wrote dispatches
for the North American newspaper
Alliance syndicate of 50 newspapers his
arrival in the country itself was a news
event that other reporters reported on
such a great writer and such an
obnoxious human being so he's in the
story scene as much as possible through
the eyes of some of my other characters
I also got fascinated by a pair of New
York Times correspondents The Times
covered the war very thoroughly from
both sides and on the the Republic side
was a man named Herbert Matthews very
well-known correspondent on Franco's
side was another correspondent who had
previously been a colleague of Matthews
in The Times Paris Bureau named William
Pete Carney each of them was a
passionate devotee of his side and the
war completely blind to its faults each
of them passionately partisan and Carney
actually later became a paid lobbyist
for Franco's nationalists in the United
States they hated each other and they
traded barbs in print in this very
restrained Times Ian way where of course
you can't name whom you're elbowing
but you can sort of trace some of these
elbow jabs going back and forth I ended
up feeling that the best American
correspondent on the scene by a longshot
was not one of the well-known ones not
Ernest Hemingway and not Martha Gellhorn
but a 26-year old woman named Virginia
cowls who is one of the very few of all
of these journalists whose book on the
subject is still well worth rereading
today 26 years old never went to college
very shrewd reporter with an eagle eye
for humbug reported both from the side
of the spanish republic and managed to
get at a nationalist spain and report
from that side even when the
nationalists worked very hard to keep
out anybody who had once reported from
the republic side so through her eyes i
can use her to sort of give a picture of
what life was like in nationalists spain
during that period now i have i was
interested in journalists because i've
done some reporting from overseas myself
on a couple of occasions from conflict
zones and one thing I've noticed about
reporters in such places is that they
tend to travel in packs they practice
they we practice a kind of herd behavior
reporters tend to keep a very close eye
on what their rivals are reporting
because nobody wants to get a message
from home in those days that came by
telegram these days that would come by
text message saying that a rival
newspaper a rival Network has reported
this battle or that announcement and why
haven't we heard anything about this
from you so everybody was very carefully
watching you know what were their
competitors reporting and this kind of
herd behavior is reinforced I think when
people are in danger and under fire you
want to give your colleagues a helping
hand show them where the bomb shelter is
and so on the reporters in Spain were
mainly on the side of the Spanish
Republic because the Nationalists
through censorship and giving everybody
a minder to follow them around made
reporting from the nationalist side
quite difficult and the reporters in the
Spanish Republic tended to stick
together they stayed in the same hotel
in Madrid
they ate dinner together every night at
the same table
that was reserved for them in the same
restaurant and afterwards they repaired
for drinks to Ernest Hemingway's suite
at the hotel and you can find
descriptions of all this in countless
memoirs now in this kind of situation
the question for me becomes what stories
did the herd miss and there were two big
ones in one case it went almost
unreported by the foreign correspondents
in Spain at the time the second case it
went entirely unreported and here's what
the stories were the first story was
this when Franco and his nationalist
made their grab for power in July 1936
in much of the country that they did not
succeed in taking over them particularly
Spain's northeast Barcelona and
surrounding Catalonia they were defeated
not by loyal army troops but by hastily
organized badly armed militias that had
been formed by left-wing political
parties and labor unions and having
beaten back this coup attempt these
working-class militias found themselves
essentially in control of huge swaths of
the country particularly Barcelona and
the surrounding area and they carried
out a social revolution without parallel
in Western European history workers took
over factories including the Ford and
General Motors plants in Barcelona which
were converted to making homemade
armored cars and other materials for the
war effort
took over those vast estates trolley car
drivers in railway look workers took
over the transportation system you can
see pictures of locomotives with the you
know initials of the anarchist trade
union on the side of the locomotive
waiters took over restaurants the Ritz
Hotel in Barcelona the fanciest in the
city waiters cooks in Busboys took over
the dining room and converted it to
people's cafeteria number one for the
poor most of these folks were driven by
the anarchist tradition which was
something very strong in Spain even as
it had gone into eclipse just about
everywhere else in the world the foreign
correspondents virtually entirely
ignored this story they were too busy
competing with each other covering the
battles especially the siege of Madrid
so how to portray all this I have
decided to portray it in the book
through the eyes of two American
eyewitnesses who saw the whole thing
they were a young couple who were in
Europe for all things on their honeymoon
louis and charles or louis or was
nineteen years old
she was a student at the University of
Louisville in Kentucky she had married
an economics instructor at the
university earlier in 1936 they were
honeymooning in France and Germany when
they got word of this remarkable social
revolution that had happened
simultaneously with the military coup in
Spain they were both leftist but of a
very independent anti-stalinist sort
Louis who was very much the live wire of
the two said to her somewhat older
somewhat STAAD your husband we have to
go there they hitchhiked to Barcelona
arriving two months after the start of
the coup and worked there for ten months
Louis wrote the most extraordinary
series of letters home during that time
and then later spent much of the rest of
her life
writing and rewriting and rewriting a
memoir about this period which she was
never able to get published but this
bottoms-up
revolution was an amazing thing that
attracted young idealists from all over
the world one for example who moved in
their circles in Barcelona was a excuse
me a 23 year old German political
refugee named villi brunt another they
met for the first time this way Charles
or was working in his office one day he
was the editor of an english-language
newspaper put out by a small left-wing
political party that was aligned with
the anarchists and the L of the
buildings elevator wasn't working the
porter came trudging upstairs and said
there's an Englishman downstairs who
doesn't speak Spanish done this would be
Catalan can I send him up and Charles
were said sure and up comes this very
tall gangly awkward
stammering fellow who says that his name
is Blair and he's come to Spain to fight
and where should he go and he cha relora
asked him what his skills were and what
kind of work he'd done and man said he'd
published a couple of novels under
another name which or had not heard of
and of course Eric Blair was George
Orwell and Charles aura was the first
person that he met in Spain and well
Orwell spent only a week in militia
bottom barracks in Barcelona before
going for the front and subsequently
wrote his remarkable memoir how much to
Catalonia the other big story of the war
was completely ignored by the
correspondents and indeed it's been
treated in a most profound way if at all
by historians since then and here's what
it was here were all these
correspondents in Madrid
Hurd writing for their newspaper all
over the world the newspapers everywhere
and one of the things they wrote about
was the experience of being in the first
major european capital to come under
heavy sustained aerial bombardment day
after day they looked up and they saw
those v-shaped formations of Hitler's
bombers in the skies above Madrid and
they never asked whose fuel is powering
those bombers because of course modern
armies run on gasoline and diesel fuel
and aviation fuel they never asked it
should have been an obvious question
because nationalist Spain had no oil
Hitler and Mussolini which were
supporting it were oil importers not
exporters it would have been very
difficult and expensive for them to
supply Franco with all his oil what was
the major source of oil in the world at
this point it was the United States
especially Texas has it turned out
General Franco was getting most of his
oil from Texaco which had a CEO at that
point a man named tor killed Reber who
was basically a fascist sympathizer
he not only supplied Franco with most of
his oil throughout the war but he
violated US law in several ways by
sending it to her American law said that
anything traveling to a country at war
could not travel on American ships
nationalist Spain had no oil tankers so
Reber loaded the oil onto Texaco tankers
at the Texaco pipeline terminal and Port
Arthur Texas and off it went to Spain
and at sea the ships were ostensibly
bound for Rotterdam Antwerp Amsterdam at
sea their captains would open sealed
orders redirecting them to ports in
nationalist Spain and that was the first
violation of US law second violation
was US law said that you could not
supply goods to a country at war on
credit nationalist Spain had no spare
cash Reber said that's no problem you
can pay us when it's over and he did
something and and he did two other
things as well he gave Franco the oil at
a huge discount something he never told
Texaco shareholders nor can nor as far
as we can tell by studying minutes of
the boards of directors meetings did he
even inform his board of directors of
this and only in recent years has it
come out through the work of a Spanish
scholar who very generously shared some
of his documents with me that Reber
provided an additional kind of help to
Franco as well here's what it was
Texaco being a major multinational oil
company had imports all over the world
installations tank farms offices agents
insurers and so on worldwide Network
Reapers sent word out to all of these
people send us immediately as you get it
any information you have regarding
tankers heading for the Spanish Republic
this information was then immediately
passed on to the nationalist High
Command where it was used by bomber
pilots and submarine captains looking
for targets because of course this
lifeline of oil the Spanish Republic was
essential it was highly targeted
twenty-nine oil tankers going to the
Spanish Republic over the course of the
war were sunk damaged or captured and in
at least one or two cases we know that
that was done with the help of
information from Texaco history books
will tell you that the United States was
neutral in the Spanish Civil War but
Texaco was not neutral so these are some
of the untold stories of the span
Civil War I think it's enough I hope
I've whetted your appetite to meet some
of the people involved in this book I'd
be glad to hear your comments or
questions but actually before we do that
I have a question for you
anybody here have a relative who was in
Spain at that time yeah just tell us who
and where where were Union the fur and
leather workers union raised money for
the first ambulance for the American
Lincoln Brigade and
ambulance John McCain's anti-fascist
Refugee Committee
and I have letters okay anyone else just
quickly your father was an American
volunteer guts were all hanging out he
says he put them back in and he heard
the guide live so somehow somehow he
made it work I don't know how but he had
an anecdote that he said that the
language the internet that because are
out there all these countries that were
there the internet the language that
they used to be able to communicate was
the other with the other countries which
Yiddish yes focus being a lingua franca
yeah I was born in Spain in 1932 you
were born in Spain in 1932 and lift in
Spain well disabled live through the
same and because I was a child didn't
suffer as much as other people would
have suffered but have very vivid
memories of the entire lives during the
Civil War I have some comments if you
would all need to make actually you know
I should press if anybody else would
like to answer that question once you
get in line so the microphone will pick
it up because I forgot that we're
supposed to put say everything into the
microphones so that the c-span which is
filming this can hear our response
that's right but that this microphone
you wanna start on it all right thank
you you know I just wanted to mention
one thing first of all your review is
fantastic and appreciated very good one
and I'm gonna read your book in great
detail the one thing I would like to
mention is that the reason that some
country such friends the United Kingdom
in the United States did not participate
in military and remain brutal is because
they were shocked in afraid of the
extreme left-wing movements in the
immediate weeks and months of the Civil
War what do you have mentioned of
Catalonia with with the Turkish that was
probably the most significant one but
what happened is that they wanted a
revolution now where's the rest of the
Republic really wanted to win the war
first and then go to a revolution later
all right so this is the background I
submit that the Republic should have won
the war but they didn't and they didn't
for two reasons primarily one is because
instead of having an organized forces
that would fight Franco instead of that
they had all these militias all of them
run by different leaders and so forth
and so that was one thing the second
thing that is really even more important
is that eventually the Republic side
falls into complete dominance by the
Soviet Union and they sent their there
are people to infiltrate the military
and then become the real leaders of the
military they deposed Largo Caballero
from the green that was more in favor of
Stalin so the whole thing was just a
minute but Stalin had this system of
distrusting infighting among themselves
and so forth in that created such a such
a disarray among the Republic military
that I think that was probably the most
important factor at which they lost
anymore they should have worn it okay
thank you
there certainly was disarray on the
Republican side there's no question
about that I guess I would question
myself whether that was the real reason
they lost the war I think the reason
they lost the war is that they were up
against an enemy that was receiving a
huge stream of arms from Hitler's
Germany Mussolini's Italy which as I
mentioned sent 80,000 ground troops as
well and the Western democracies did
nothing
initially the position that it was
disarray on the Republican side which
caused Franklin the Nationalists to win
George Orwell took that position when he
wrote homage to Catalonia five years
later he changed his mind and he said
the course of the war was decided in
London Paris Berlin and he should have
added Washington to the list I think
those were the that was the real reason
for the loss of the
yeah my name is Chris Hinkle and my
father was a reporter for New York Times
and he spent six months in Spain what in
what years 38 38 January to June mm-hmm
and he saw a lot of conflict and he got
to meet Franco a number of times he
covered the Franco side uh-huh and
herbert matthews covered the right
loyalist side but they knew each other
well huh and my father knew Hemingway
and he gained a great friendship with
Martha Gellhorn and saved her life maybe
a half-dozen times because she was
reckless
yes Mary do come anyway she had to be
but anyway whenever he was in a battle
zone where there were American
volunteers captured he made a point to
have them rescued because they were
going to be shot that's true they were
there were outsiders
many were naive they were cannon fodder
and he actually saved Milton Wolf's life
ones who became head of the Abraham
Lincoln brigade in New York that's right
and head of the Abraham Lincoln
battalion in Spain yeah and one last
story oh he was in a Esau battle and
they captured ten american abraham
lincoln people and the captain who liked
but the captain of the spaniards who
liked my father a lot and knew he was
close to Franco said you pick five to
live and so what my father did he
interviewed them thoroughly and they
thought this I want to be in the
newspaper and the ones he saved were the
young ones who hadn't seen any battle
but some of them there were two that
were pretty bad though they were thugs
and they had done a lot of destruction
and essentially the questions he asked
what battles have you been in and when
they said I was in this one or that one
where he know where he knew there were
atrocities he made sure they were giving
up you
but one of the people he saved he was
very proud of this was a young Jewish
medical student who had gone over to
Spain as a as an adventurer he saved his
life he ended up back in Spain
repatriated he then this young medical
student then got her on a Merchant
Marine ship and that was actually
torpedoed off the coast of Africa he was
the owner survivor of the torpedo ship
he had enough of war he goes back to
Colombia becomes a doctor and delivers
over 10,000 babies and my father read
his obit in the Washington Post and my
father said that's the best thing I ever
did in the war and that's a true story
good for him good for him thank you
thank you I'd be interested in hearing
about some of the obstacles you faced
collecting your research materials
problems getting access to letters that
clearly were no longer in the possession
of the people that held them and those
kinds of things well actually I didn't
run into a lot of obstacles maybe
because there is such rich material in
this period that when a pathway was
blocked here I could very easily find
someone else to focus on for anyone
writing about this this time there is
really a rich array of materials to draw
from from the American veterans for
example those who were in the
International Brigades of the 2,800
young men and a number of women a lot of
nurses went to Spain as well
of the 2800 who went there our diaries
letters documents of some sort on
probably more than 250 of them most of
which are in the Talmud library of New
York University and to have roughly 10%
of the survivors of anything
historical leave materials behind that
you can work from is a gold mine for a
historian
the one kind of thing that I wish I had
found more of and didn't was records of
some of the Americans who did not fight
in the International Brigades but fought
for example in george orwell's militia
unit there was an american harry milton
of new york who was standing next to
Orwell in the trenches when he was shot
there his unit had an American doctor
unfortunately no papers from either of
these folks or any of the other handful
of Americans whom we know were there at
that time have survived journalists tend
to keep everything so there was a lot of
material from the various journalists
who covered the war
Herbert Matthews of the New York Times
kept every capped a carbon copy of every
dispatch he sent to the paper's
headquarters in New York so that people
like me and us years later could see how
terribly these were censored and
condensed by the times as editors in New
York before they finally appeared in the
newspaper I actually concluded that they
did not do a lot of political censorship
but the Matthews was quite long-winded
and is one of those reporters as the
many editors and former editors here
know certain reporters who get wildly
offended any time you cut a sentence out
of their stories
so I found just an abundance of material
to work from and as I mentioned I think
it's always fun when you can put
documents together that cast several
different lights several different kinds
of light on the same event and sometimes
even the same person saying something
differently at different points in time
a little example of that for example in
Hemingway's novel about the war for Whom
the Bell Tolls and incidentally the
central episode in that novel the
blowing up of a bridge
uh nationalists lungs Hemingway himself
took part in a raid that blew up a
bridge behind nationalist nine and I
tell that story in the book anyway in
that novel he paints annex quarry ating
picture are correctly excoriating
picture of Stalin's men who was charged
in charge of the International Brigades
Andre Marti a French communist and when
the book appeared in this country the
communist press was outraged because
they had expected Hemingway's
much-anticipated novel about the war
would be about working-class men from
you know different countries standing
shoulder-to-shoulder in the fight
against fascism and instead the hero of
the nala novel is a former college
professor who's a lover of Spanish
literature whose kind of non political
and here is this excoriating portrait of
Stalin's leading commissar in Spain and
one American Party official in Spanish
Civil War veteran and himself offer of
quite a good know more about the war
alphabetty reviewed the novel in a
communist party publication and talked
about how you know dreadful it was that
Hemingway a distorted history in this
way and said these insulting things
about you know the great anti-fascist
fighter Andre Marti
well you compare it with Bessey's own
diary from Spain about when he met an
Andre Marti and found him a thug and a
demagogue and says so in his diary so
it's wonderful fun sort of putting
together things like that
sure quick question so I recall him one
of the books I read mentioned was made
that when Franco's forces finally
marched into Barcelona that one of the
political one of the first political
leaders they executed happened to be
president of FC Barcelona the the soccer
team in your research did you find out
anything about sort of that the role of
the soccer club in the resistance I did
not that sounds like as I mentioned I
think yes you could write a whole other
book about this period with a whole
different set of characters and the
stories would be equally fascinating oh
it's my wife Frank casanov whose dad was
in Spain I never knew him I wish I had
I've heard about him 30 years for 30
years I've lived in the shadow
I can't measure up that's daddy the war
hero he also was in the London Blitz she
didn't mention he was shot he was
wounded what in the stomach he said and
he met Hemingway and said he was
arrogant and I said my friend Gayle
Gottlieb here his dad was in the brigade
so a couple questions quickly what would
Spain have looked like if the Republican
one would have been Stalinist would have
been democratic and if the Republican
one would Hitler and Mussolini maybe not
have started the war good questions
ah I think if the Spanish Republic had
won the war the people of Spain would
have been much better off there are
right-wing historians who say well if
the Republican wanted would have become
a Soviet satellite and it's true that
the Soviets did have great influence and
the Army and the security police but I
think to effectively turn a country into
a satellite you have to have military
occupation the Soviet satellites in
Eastern Europe could remain that way for
40 years because the Red Army was on
hand and Moscow didn't help - didn't
didn't stop - deployed and didn't
hesitate to deploy it when somebody got
out of line as in Hungary 1956
East Germany 1953 Czechoslovakia in 1968
similarly the u.s. kept most nations in
Central America and the Caribbean doing
pretty much what it wanted throughout
the 20th centuries through a ceaseless
string of military interventions without
the Red Army occupying a republic in
Spain I don't think it would have been a
Soviet satellite what kind of country
would it have been
I think democratic disorganized chaotic
but not a military dictatorship
furthermore and this sort of gets to the
second question you asked if the
Republic had won the war Spain would not
have been a de facto Ally for Hitler in
World War two
Spain never formally joined the at the
Atlas pound VIII the Axis powers in
world war ii but Franco gave Hitler a
base for 21 attack submarines on Spain's
Atlantic Coast bases for reconnaissance
aircraft radio listening posts
encouraged 45,000 young Spaniards to
volunteer for Hitler's army and his
doomed invasion of Russia and most
important supplied Hitler with a stream
of strategic metals and minerals
throughout the war things that were very
important allies in making weapons if
the Republican Spain had won Hitler
would not have had that de facto ally in
World War two I don't think it would
have stopped Hitler from launching the
Second World War
because I think Spain for Hitler was
always something of a sideshow his real
ambition was to show Russia who was boss
and control Eastern Europe and the
western parts of the Soviet Union and
reached the Balkan and Caspian oil
fields I don't think a loss in Spain
would have deterred him from that thank
you so much thank you
[Applause]